boys some of y'all are out here
looking straight goofy when y'all submit
these fraudulent
ppp loans and you're not sophisticated
your total amateurs you're gonna go to
jail for being such an idiot
so today we're going to look at some of
the dumbest things i've seen
welcome to the ppp chronicles something
like the lie about the size of the
peppers and they will be cut
or they will be gotten if you have a
small ppp that is okay
but you must not lie to the government
not the government
maybe a new girlfriend
welcome to the beep beep beep beep beep
beep
chronical ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the fbi building
where i'm gonna just recount to you the
fact that the fbi has now gotten
involved with some of these ppp fraud
cases they have something called the
complex financial crimes squad or
something like that it sounds
much cooler than it probably is ladies
and gentlemen welcome to my presentation
screen we here at the fbi you know
10 million dollar studio now today we're
looking at joshua bellamy's
criminal complaint joshua bellamy is the
former nfl player he was a wide receiver
for the jets
so um brilliant man in the art of
complex financial crimes and uh how he
got
caught he had something called drip
entertainment llc
and he was one of many people nine
people were charged
submitting false documents and trying to
get money for it from the coveted relief
fund and this guy
got one million two hundred thousand
dollars
now he got this at a time when he was
broke apparently when he
got it the 1.2 million dollars at the
time in his personal account he had a
personal balance of 2.51
now i know what you're thinking poor guy
maybe he needed the money well
he spent that 1.2 million dollars
in two months yeah that's who we're
dealing with and
was it on food was it on shelter no he
spent it on
custom jewelry uh fifty seven thousand
dollars in custom jewelry thirty eight
thousand dollars on another jewelry
store
five thousand dollars at gucci a
thousand dollars you guys get the point
he's trying to get the drip drip and uh
he got caught and i don't feel bad for
him about it i mean the level of this
scam was so low there's such amateurs
at this little organization look at this
the purported company bank statement
which was submitted in electronic for
uh format is a clear forgery first
according to the documents file
properties
the statement was created using pdf
filler
a program used to edit electronic pdf
files
i bet the fbi people and all the people
who investigated this were like
are you joking you're trying to get one
bias with pdf filler
it was probably like the free version or
something like that and was modified
using
itext second the statement is a recycled
version of
the same falsified bank 7 statement used
in other fraudulent applications
submitted as part of the scheme
oh my gosh they're not even bothering to
redo documents they're submitting the
same stuff
but as if that's not enough they then
went and entrapped this guy dude the
fbi's crushing it i'll tell them
this criminal complaint is just scathing
apparently an undercover
agent posed as an associate and spoke
with the guy basically saying hey i get
you a second ppp loan
and you'd think this guy this jets wide
receiver who just got 1.2 million
dollars from the government
fraudulently would say hey man no no
no way dude i can't do that i'm not
going to
lie to the government in order to get
more money i've already stolen money
from the government
but instead he goes yeah of course let's
do it right
how stupid can you be let me answer that
question
with his co-conspirator his
co-conspirator is a little smarter it's
a guy named philip
augustine who was investigated by the
fbi
now this augustine guy tried to claim
since he was just the hype man for this
business
he tried to claim that look it wasn't
his doing he was a victim
it says that it was chs2 who's just this
other guy who's unnamed
who submitted the application from
augustine's house using augustine's
computer
your honor i didn't i it may have come
from my computer
the fraud may have been found on my
computer but
i did not touch my computer in fact
he later told uh prosecutors that he was
he was only providing documents while he
was playing two games of pool and didn't
know that any fraud was happening
now the problem with that was that they
went and they checked his phone records
like these people think that the
government's incompetent which in a lot
of ways it is but
they think that there's no such thing as
telephone records and basically the
telephone records paint a different
picture
because this alleged victim and the guy
preparing the documents
were texting back and forth the whole
time and why would you text back and
forth from the same room
if one of you guys are playing pool so
it doesn't make sense
not only that his signatures match the
same signatures
from his bank records from all his
private records and so they're like yeah
you definitely did this crime
but now because this guy lied to
prosecutors because he tried to cover up
his crime and try to say no i was the
victim
look at this in that interview he
falsely portrayed himself to be the
victim
he might be getting prosecuted under
obstruction of
the investigation which to me i'm loving
it i'm
all here for watching these scammers get
exposed
you know i i love this stuff look you
lie to the government you lie to the
american people you say you have these
businesses that are saving jobs you get
paid
and then you go blow it all like have
you noticed it's a common theme with the
ppp chronicles that all these people
they don't just get the loan money and
then go help the poor
right they don't get the low money and
go feed
puppies at the at the shelter they get
the loan money and
spend it on custom jewelry like these
people have no shame they don't even
think they're gonna get caught
they're too arrogant to think that
they're gonna get caught and when they
do
oh i love it and just know if you're out
there scamming
they're gonna catch you these people are
not dumb while reading these case files
i was like
damn boy i didn't know they could do
that
they're checking the text logs the phone
logs they're checking
yeah dude they're checking how many
squares you use on the toilet trust me
these people know you better than you
know yourself by the time they've
investigated you
so don't think you're gonna get away
with it you may get away with it for a
little bit
you may be arrogant you may be in your
new bins that you just bought thinking
oh man i got away
with it let me apply for another covet
loan no dude
you just got away with it for now you're
gonna get caught
and when they bust you you will be
appearing in the ppp chronicles and we
will be
celebrating your downfall because you're
stealing money
anyways that's it guys let me know what
you think in the comments below and as
always
don't forget to smash like and subscribe
thank you
a mouthful of money